if we look back 10 15 years ago you see
the the communication community is more
diverse you see all kinds of merchants
any masses you see all kinds of
knowledge is further from physics from
optical field or getting into this field
to try to tackle the problem from multi
perspective as we are emphasizing that
Wesley everywhere I think the scientific
community is going to be Morehouse if we
have diverse perspective you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen using in technical terms
computer vision researchers build
algorithms and systems to automatically
analyze imagery and extract knowledge
from the visual world in layman's terms
they build machines that can see and
that's exactly what principal researcher
and research manager dr. ganghwa and the
computer vision technology team are
doing because being able to see is
really important for things like the
personal robots self-driving cars and
autonomous drones we're seeing more and
more in our daily lives today dr. bois
talks about how the latest advances in
AI and machine learning are making big
improvements on image recognition video
understanding and even the arts he also
explains the distributed ensemble
approach to active learning where humans
and machines work together in the lab to
get computer vision systems ready to see
and interpret the open world that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
ganghwa hi hello welcome to the podcast
great to have you here thanks for
waiting me you're a principal researcher
and the research manager at MSR in your
focuses computer vision research in
broad strokes right now what gets a
computer vision researcher up in the
morning what's the big goal yeah
communication is a relatively young
research field in January you can think
this field is trying to build machines
to endow computers the capability to
just see the world and interpret the
world just like human from a more
technical side of you it's the input to
the computer is really just the image
and videos you can think of them as a
sequence of numbers but one week once we
extract from these images and videos
from these numbers it's some sort of
structures of the world or some
semantically information out of it for
example I could see this part of the
image really corresponds to a kept that
part of the image corresponds to a car
this type of integration so that's the
goal of communication like for us human
it looks to be a simple task to achieve
but in order to teach computers to do it
we really have made a lot of progress in
the past 10 years but there's a research
field this thing has been there for 50
years still yet a lot of problems to
tackle and I just yeah in fact you gave
a talk about five years ago uh-huh where
you said in I paraphrase after 30 years
of research why should we still care
about face recognition research tell us
how you answered then and now where you
think we are so I think that status quo
five years ago I would see like at that
moment if we capture a slapshot of how
the research in facial recognition has
progressed since the beginning of
communication or face recognition
research I would say we achieved a lot
but more in controlled environment where
you could carefully control the lighting
the camera setting and all those kind of
scenes when
you are framing the faces at that moment
the five years ago when we move towards
more like wow the settings like faces
taking under uncontrolled environment I
would say there's a huge gap there in
terms of recognition accuracy but in the
past five years I would say the whole
community also made a lot of progress
leveraging like the more advanced the
deep learning techniques even for facial
recognition in the wild scenario we've
made a lot of progress and really have
pushed this things to a stage where a
lot of commercial applications becomes
feasible yeah so deep learning has
really enabled even recently some great
advances in the field of computer vision
and computer recognition of images right
so that's interesting when you talk
about the difference between a highly
controlled situation versus recognizing
things in the wild and I've had a couple
of researchers on here who've said yeah
where computers fail is when the
datasets are not full enough for example
dog dog dog three-legged dog mmm is it
still a dog right what kinds of things
do deep learning techniques give you
that you didn't have before
in these recognition advances yeah
that's a great question from a research
perspective below the power of deep
learning with as in several facts the
first thing is that it can conduct with
the Linnaean end-to-end fashion and
learn what's the right representation
for that semantic pattern for example
when we're talking about a dog if we
really look into all kinds of pictures
of a talk
although see if my input is really a 64
by 64 images suppose each pixel has like
a 250 values to take that's a huge space
if you think about it a combination but
when we talk about dog ads a pattern
like actually every pixels correlated a
little bit so the actual pattern for dog
is going to result in a much lower
dimensional space right so the power of
deep learning is that I can connect the
learning in under 20 fashioned really
learn to write you
medical representation for talk and
because of the deep structures we can
come out with really complicated models
which can really digest a large amount
of training data yeah so that means like
if my training I recovered all kinds of
variations like of all kinds of wheels
of this pattern eventually I can
recognize it in a broader setting
because I have covered almost all the
spaces okay so another capability of
deep learning is that this kind of
compositional behavior because he's a
layer a feed forward structure and layer
the representation there so when the
information or image get the fit into
deep networks and it starts by
extracting some very low-level image
primitives then gradually the model can
assemble all those primitives together
and form a higher and higher level of
semantic structures so in this sense it
captures all the small pendants
corresponding to the bigger presence and
compose them together to represent the
fan of head and so that's why it is very
powerful especially for visual
recognition tasks right so yeah so the
broad umbrella of cvpr yes it's computer
vision pattern recognition right and a
lot of that pattern recognition is what
the techniques are really driving - sure
yeah so that's actually communication
really is trying to making sense out of
pixels if we talk about it in a really
mechanical way is that I fit in the
image you either extract the some
numerical output or some symbolic output
from it till you mark output for example
could be a 3d point cloud which
described the structure of the scene or
the shape of object it could also be
corresponding to some semantic labels
like a dog and cat as I mentioned at the
beginning so yeah so we'll get to
labeling in a bit sure it's an
interesting
whole part of the machine learning
process is that it has to be fed labels
as well as pixels sure right yeah
[Music]
you have three main areas of interest in
your computer vision research that we
talked about video faces and arts and
media let's talk about each of those in
turn and start with your current
research in what you call video
understanding yes we do understanding
like the title was sort of explaining
itself instead of the input allowed
becomes a video stream instead of a
single image we're reasoning about
pixels and how they move if we view
communication reasoning about the single
images as a spatial reasoning problem
now we are talking about a
spatial-temporal reasoning problem
because video it's the third dimensional
that temporal dimension and if you look
into a lot of real world problem we're
talking about continuous video streams
whether it is a surveillance camera in a
building or a traffic camera overseeing
highways you have this constant flow of
frames coming in and the object inside
it is moving so you want to basically
digest information out of it when you
talk about those kinds of cameras mm-hmm
it gives us massive amounts of video you
know constant stream of cameras and
security in the 7-eleven and things like
that what is your group trying to do on
behalf of humans with those video
streams sure
so one incubation project we are doing
like my team is building the
foundational technology turn one
incubation project we are trying to do
is to really analyze the traffic on
roads if you think about the a city when
they set up all those traffic cameras
most of the way to streams are actually
wasted but if you carefully think about
it these cameras are smart just the
thing about one scenario where you want
to more intelligently controlled traffic
lights so if in one direction I saw a
lot more traffic flow instead of having
a fixed schedule of turn on and turn off
those red lights and the green lights
I could see like okay because these
sites has less cars or even no cars at
this moment I would allow the other
direction their green eyes to
keep longer time so that the traffic and
flow better so that's just the one type
of application there could you please
get that out there I mean it's yeah
because how many of us have sat at a
traffic light when it's red and there's
no traffic coming the other way exactly
why can't take oh yeah you could also
think about some other applications like
if we accumulated videos across years if
there's citizens requesting like we set
up additional bicycle lanes we could use
the videos we have analyzing what the
traffic data there and then decide if it
makes sense to set up a bike lender if
we set it with the sort of significantly
effect that the other traffic flows and
hope the cities to make decisions like
that I think this is so brilliant
because a lot of times we make decisions
based on you know our own ideas rather
than data that says you know hey this is
where a bike lane would be terrific this
is where it would actually ruin
everything for lady right for sure yes
they sometimes they leverages some other
type of sensors to do that you li you
hire company like it set up some special
equipments on the roads to do that but
it's very costly effective just the
thing about all those cameras are
sitting there the video streams are
there yeah so that's a fantastic
explanation of what you can do with
machine learning and video understanding
right yeah yeah another area you care
about is faces and kind of harkens back
to that why should we still care about
facial recognition research but yeah and
this line of research has some really
interesting applications talk about
what's happening with facial recognition
research who's doing it and what's new
yeah so indeed if we look back a facial
recognition technologists progress team
Microsoft I think that when I was live
labs research we set up the first
official recognition library which could
be leveraged by different product teams
indeed the first adopter is xbox they
tried to use facial recognition
technology of automatically user login
at that moment I think that's the first
adoption over the time like a facial
recognition research the sender sort of
migrated through measures of research
Asia
where we still have a group or research
as I collaborate ways we are
continuously trying to push the state of
the art out this is what become a
synergistic efforts where we have
engineering teams helping us to gather
more data and then we just trim better
models our research recently actually
focused more on Lyle research we call
identity preserving frees synthesize so
recently there is a big advancement in
deep learning community which is the
establishment of using deep networks to
generative models which can model the
distribution of images so that you can
draw from that distribution basically
synthesize image you build a deep
networks which the output is an image
indeed
so what we want to achieve is actually a
step further we want to synthesize faces
well we want to keep the identity of
those faces saying we don't want the our
algorithms to just randomly symbol a set
of face out without any semantic
information so you want to generate the
face of brother Pete I want to really
generally the face looks like Brad Pitt
if I want to generate the face similar
to anybody at all I think we just want
to be able to achieve that so the
identity preservation is the sort of
outcome that you're aiming for of the
person that you're trying to generate
the face up right you know tangentially
I wonder if you get this technology
going does it morph with you as you get
older and start to recognize you or do
you have to keep updating your face
yeah that's a new that very good
question I I would see in general we
actually have some ongoing research
trying to tackle that problem I think
for using technology yes you need to
update your face maybe from time to time
especially if you under done a lot of
changes for you know somebody who could
have done some plastic surgery that will
basically pray God that a minute that's
not you sure no let me hahaha there are
several ways can sing about it like a
human faces actually don't change much
like between age seventeen eighteen when
you grow up all the way to maybe 50
ish they don't change much so when
people first go to born mega kids their
face actually changes a lot because
there's a growing impulse and basically
the shape and the skin could change a
lot but once people get matured into a
doubt of the stage the change is very
slow so we actually have some research
wave trying to model the aging process -
that will help establish better facial
recognition system cross Shh this is
actually a very good kind of technology
which can allow you to get into the loin
in reinforcements domain for example
some missing kids they couldn't have
been kidnapped by somebody but after
many years if you know different yeah
they look different if the smart facial
recognition algorithms can match the
original photos and the you may say what
they would look like at maybe 14 if they
were kidnapped earlier yes yes exactly
wow that's a great application yeah so
well let's talk about the other area
that you're actively pursuing and that's
media and the arts mm-hm tell us how
research is overlapping with art and
particularly what with your work in deep
artistic style transfer sure if we look
into people's desire right first we need
to eat and we need to drink and we need
to sleep okay then once all these tasks
are fulfilled actually we human as a
strong design of Arts and I creation and
the creation and things like that so
this seemed of researching commissioned
we linked it to like a more artistic
type of what we call media and arts like
basically using communication
technologists to give people a good
artistic enjoyment so the particular
research project we have done in the
past two years is a sequence of
algorithms where we can render an image
into any sort of artistic Estelle's you
want as long as you provide example of
that artistic style for example we can
render a imager to one Gauss style
thank you yeah or any other painters
finished oh yeah yeah or Picasso yeah
all of them if you can think of
interesting with pixels with big shows
yeah those are again
like all done by deep networks and some
people and in technologists we designed
it sounds like you need a lot of
disciplines to feed into this research
yeah where are you getting all of your
talent from in terms of in a sense I
always see our golf and this is making
yellow artworks are not lessons very
accessible to everyone like some of
these artworks are really expensive yeah
by this kind of digital technology what
we are trying to do is make these kind
of artworks to be accessible to common
users yeah Democrats it yes you
mentioned mega so our algorithm allows
us to build the explicit representation
like a numerical representation for each
can Estelle then if you want to create a
loose tiles we can blend them so that is
like we are building a art space where
we can explore in between to see how
this visual effects needs evolve in
between like a to paint there some
scenes like that and even have deeper
understanding how they compose their
artistic style and it seems like that
yeah what's really interesting to me is
that this is a really quantitative field
computer science algorithm sure a lot of
math and numbers and then you've got art
over here which is much more
metaphysical sure
and yet you're bringing them together
and it's revealing the artistic side of
the quantitative brain sure I seem to
bring all these things together the
biggest of the tool we are leveraging
indeed is statistics as all kinds of
machinery Arizona Sardinia is really
trying to capture just statistics of the
pixels
[Music]
let's get a little technical yeah we
have been a little technical but some of
your recently published work and our
listeners can find that on both VMs our
website and your website sure you talked
about a new distributed ensemble
approach to active learning uh-huh tell
us what's different about that what you
proposed how it's different what does it
promise
yeah that's indeed a great question I
think when we are talking about the
active Linnaean we are referring for a
process where we have some sort of humor
Oracle involved in the Linnaean process
in traditional active learning we were
seeing that I have a learning machine
this learning machine can intelligently
pick up some data samples and ask the
human Oracle to provide a little bit
more input so the learning machine
actually picks assembles and ask of the
humor go actually provide freedom by a
label for this image so in this work
when we are talking about the ensemble
machine we are actually dealing with a
more complicated problem we are trying
to factor active learning into actually
in a crowdsourcing environment if you
think about the Amazon Mechanical Turk
now this is really one of the pigs of
the platform where people send their
data and ask the crowd workers to label
all of them but in this process if you
were not careful the labels you
connected from this process for your
data could be quite lousy in rain yeah
they may not be able to be used by you
so so in this process we actually try to
achieve to go stir the first ago we want
to smartly distribute the data so that
we can make the label to be most cost
effective okay the second is that we
want to actually assess the quality of
all my crowd workers so that maybe even
in the online process I can purposely
send my data to the good workers to
label so that's how our model works so
actually we have a somewhat a
distributed one like each crowd workers
corresponds to one of these linear
machines and we try to do a statistical
check
across all the models so that in the
same process we actually comes out with
a quality score for each of the crowd
workers on the fly so that we can use
the model to not only select examples
but also send the data to the label or
switch the highest quality to label them
that way with the progress of this label
efforts I can quickly come out with a
good model that leads me to the
human-in-the-loop issue and the
necessity of the checks and balances
between humans and machines uh-huh
aside from from what you're just talking
about sure how are you tackling other
issues of quality control by using
humans with your machines I have been
thinking about this problem for a while
mainly in the context of robotics if you
think about any intelligent system I
will see unless you are in a really
closed world setting then you may have a
system which can roughly autonomously
but whenever we hit the open world like
a kernel machine any machine learning
based inheritance system are not
necessarily good in dealing with all
kinds of open world cases because
there's color cases which you may have
lot being covered and variables that you
don't think about exactly so one thing I
have been singing is that how could we
really engage human in that loop till
what I only help the intelligent agent
when they need it and also at the same
time forming some mechanism which we can
teach this agent to be able to handle
similar situations in the future I will
give you a very specific example when I
was at the Stevens Institute of
Technology I had a project from NIH
which is we call the coal robots
he's a it's a tiny robots car robots is
actually a wheelchair robots the idea is
that as long as the user can move their
leg we actually have a head mounted
camera which the user can move their
head we use the head mounted camera
actually to track the pose of the head
and let the users to be able to control
the wheelchair robots indeed but we
don't want the user to control it all
the time so our goal is actually say if
you know home setting
one of these wheelchair rubbers to be
able to carry the user and move largely
autonomously inside the room whenever
the user came back I didn't see hey I
want to go to by room then the
wheelchair robots would mostly
autonomous lubrication but if they're
always sort of encounter a situation
that's what low how to do is it for
example how to move around then at that
moment we're gonna ask the robots to
proactively ask the human for control
then the users will control the robots
and deal with their situation
maybe next time these robots in under
similar situation they're going to be
able to deal with it again
[Music]
what were you doing before you came here
and how did you end up at Microsoft
Research this is my second term in
Microsoft so as I mentioned the first
term is between like 2006 and 2009 when
I was in lab coded live labs that's my
first term during that tenure I
established the first face recognition
library then I kind of called attracted
by external world a little bit so I went
to low key research IBM research and I
landed a Stevens Institute of Technology
as a faculty member there so and that's
over in New Jersey right yeah that's in
New Jersey in the East Coast and then in
2015 I come back to Microsoft Research
but in the paging nap first
I I transferred back actually in 2017 it
was my family stayed here I said so now
you are here in Redmond after Beijing
how did that move happen my family
always stayed in Seattle so Microsoft
Research Beijing now is a great place
obviously like I really enjoyed it
one of the unique scene there is the
super super dynamic research intern
program so year-round there's several
hundred intern actually works in the lab
and they collaborate closely with their
mentor I think it's a really telling
environment there but I lost my family
is in Seattle so I sort of explored a
little bit and then the intelligent
group is setting up this communication
group there so that's why I joined yeah
back in Seattle again yeah so I asked
this question of all the researchers
that come on the podcast and I'll ask
you - mm-hmm is there anything about
your work that we should be concerned
about what I say is anything that keeps
you up at night I would say when we talk
about the especially in the
communication domain I think privacy is
potentially the largest concern if now
you look into all countries there are
hundreds of millions of cameras are set
up everywhere in public domain or in
buildings and notes I would say like
with the technology advancement
it is really not sci-fi to expect that
cameras can now really check people all
the time I mean everything has two sides
I would see yeah these are my hands that
could help us so for example to better
dealing with criminals but for ordinary
citizens like there's a lot of privacy
concerns in this so what kinds of things
and this is why I asked this question
because it prompts people to think okay
I have this power hmm because of this
great technology uh-huh what could
possibly go wrong what kinds of things
can we be thinking about and instituting
or implementing mm-hm
to not have that problem Microsoft has a
bigger force on gdpr and I think that's
great because this is a mechanism to
ensure everything we produce actually go
that aligned with certain regulation on
the other hand everything need to strike
for a balance between usability and the
secret or privacy if you think about it
like you use some online services like
your activities basically leave traces
there that's how it is used that you
better serve you for the future but if
you want to be more convenient sometimes
you need to give up a little bit of
information out but you don't want to
give all your information out right I
think that the boundary is actually not
black and white we simply need to
carefully control that so that we just
get the right amount of information to
serve the customer better but not
unneeded the information or information
that the users are not comfortable or
feeling well too so it seems like
there's a trend towards permissions and
agency of the user sure to say I'm
comfortable with this but I'm not
comfortable with that
mm-hmm right as we finish up here
Naing talk about what you see on the
horizon for the next generation of
computer vision researchers one of the
big unsolved problems that might prompt
exciting breakthroughs or just be the
grind for the next ten years that's a
great question and also a very big
question there are big problems we
I actually shoot at a co if you think
about like Lao communication really
leverage statistical machine learning a
lot we can change recognition models
which achieved great results but that
process is largely still appear in space
so we need to better get in some of the
fundamentals in communication which is
3d geometry into the perception process
okay and there's also other scenes like
that especially when we are talking
about video understanding it's a
holistic problem where you need to do
spatial-temporal reasoning and we need
to be able to sector more cognition
concepts into this process like a causal
inference if something happened what
really a cause of this seemed to happen
machine learning techniques mostly deals
ways like correlation between data okay
correlation the causality are two
totally different concepts there so so I
feel that also needs to happen and some
of the fundamental problems so like
learning from small data and even
learning from language potentially we
need to address is the thing about how
we human Allen you will learn in two
ways
learning from experience but there is a
lot of fact that we learn from language
for example well we are talking with
each other
indeed the similes through language I've
already learned a lot from you for
example and I you yeah that's a very
compact the information flow we allow
centrally focused on people ending if we
look back like a 10-15 years ago you see
the the communication community is more
diverse you see all kinds of merge in
any masses you see all kinds of
knowledge esperado from physics from
optical field or getting into this field
to try to tackle the problem from multi
perspective as we are emphasizing that
Wesley
everywhere I think the scientific
community is going to be more house if
we have diverse perspective and tackling
the problem from multiple perspective
you know that's great advice because as
the community welcomes new researchers
they want to have
big thinkers broad thinkers divergent
thinkers just sort of push for the next
big breakthrough yep exactly
ganghwa thank you for coming in it's
been really illuminating and I've really
enjoyed our conversation thank you very
much to learn more about dr. Gangwon and
the amazing advances in computer vision
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]